cheetah's you probably already know
they're the world's fastest land animal
they can go from zero to 60 in three
seconds covering the length of an asian
elephant with each stride but here are
five things you probably didn't know
about cheetahs cheetahs are one of the
few big cats that can't roar instead
these carnivores purr much like a house
cat also they chirp loudly enough to be
heard a mile away
these chirps Gary from cheetah to
cheetah one theory is that this may
allow them to identify each other
cheetahs are the only big cat that can't
fully retract their claws
Aysen onyx jubatus is a cheetah
scientific name
Aysen onyx means no move claw in greek
their claws are actually more similar to
a dogs than to those of other cats
helping cheetahs maintain traction and
gain speed while running their muscular
tail which can be over two and a half
feet long helps cheetahs whether hunting
prey the tail acts like a rudder
allowing cheetahs to quickly change
direction while running it provides
counterbalance as they zigzag across
grasslands during a chase
unlike other big cats cheetahs hunt
primarily by day relying on their
exceptionally keen eyesight dark tear
marks below cheetahs eyes may help
reduce glare from the Sun much like the
eye black that some professional
athletes wear without the cover of
darkness
cheetahs camouflage themselves in the
tall grass of the savanna typically
getting as close as a football fields
width away from their prey before making
the chase
while most cheetahs live in Africa a
subspecies of the big cat lives in
central Iran these Asiatic cheetahs are
genetically distinct from their African
counterparts unfortunately they're
critically endangered with only an
estimated 50 individuals remaining the
cheetah population has declined from an
estimated 100,000 in the early 1900's to
around 7,000 today according to recent
estimates cheetahs are under threat from
humans
poaching habitat loss and vehicle
collisions have contributed to their
decline plus humans hunt antelopes
warthogs and other prey species that
cheetahs rely on in Namibia farmers
sometimes shoot cheetahs in retaliation
for livestock killings one successful
conservation program involves placing
livestock guarding dogs with farmers the
dogs scare away these big cats which are
built more for speed than fighting
[Music]
[Applause]